The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: The first
sheet on the handout really--
I forgot to give it
to you last time.
It's simply the argument
that for every major ideology
associated with the
change of a city,
there's a housing type
which it generates as well.
And this is just a little
sketch of some of the work
that we've done in the classes--
London, Paris, Vienna,
Barcelona, Sunnyside Gardens,
and so on.
For those of you who are
interested in architecture,
that should be a help.
There are not many cities which
originated in the 19th century.
Chicago is one of them and
probably the major one.
What was the population
of Chicago in eighteein
[INAUDIBLE] It doesn't matter.
There were a few Indians
living on a piece of land
which connects the lake
to the Mississippi River.
And Chicago-- I think
it'd be silly to ask you
what Chicago means.
It's an Indian name for
something, wild garlic.
Many cities have an affection
for nature in their names.
Bang Makok is the Village
of Wild Plum in Thailand.
Mumba Devi is the
godess of fishermen.
What is Boston?
Saint [INAUDIBLE] town--
Saint [INAUDIBLE] is the
god of fishermen, I think.
Certainly, Boston comes
from Saint [INAUDIBLE] town.
Now, the extraordinary
thing about Chicago
is, compared to the cases
we've done up to now--
number one, that
it has no walls.
Number two, it has no royalty.
It has no invested aristocracy.
What else doesn't it have?
STUDENT: History?
[INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
No, you're right.
You're right, absolutely right.
The argument for Chicago has
always been [INAUDIBLE] OK.
Be why we talk about
these generalities.
The second page on your
handout is 100 years
of building activity in Chicago
done by Homer Hoyt, the man who
did the [? vector ?] theory
of city form, which we dealt
with a couple of weeks ago.
This categorizes building
activity in the city.
And we will go through
it stage by stage.
But it's remarkable that we
can depict Chicago's history
in terms of economic
activity, whereas we
haven't used that as an index
for any of the other cases.
Chicago is built by
the private sector.
It has no city--
or such a weak and corrupt
city government that everything
about Chicago in its
19th-century period,
certainly, was based on the
primacy of the individual
making his own way
against all odds.
Chicago is referred to
as the city of wind,
not because the wind blows
there but because of the hubris
of its politicians
and its salesmen.
Wind refers to the
air that's blown out
of the mouth when you brag.
I will go through
this in more detail.
In 1848, when the railroads
crossed this country
and made their major
midwestern stop in Chicago
instead of St.
Louis, which would
have been a more
direct route, this
was all because of the
bullshit of politicians.
In 1893, when the
Chicago World's Fair
celebrated 400 years
after Columbus,
it should have
gone to St. Louis.
But it went to Chicago.
Chicago is the only city
in the world which built
the first skyscrapers on sand.
It's the first city in the
world and the only city
in the world which built an
illegal subway system, 50
miles of illegal subway
built by private development
without the city knowing.
Or if they knew, they
were submerged in bribes.
I will go through all
of these examples.
So we can characterize
Chicago adequately
in Park and Burgess's model
of a concentric universe
in which movement is outwards.
To make it in Chicago,
you need to immigrate.
And the immigration zone is
the inner zone of transition.
And then you make it,
and you move outwards.
American cities are primarily
immigrant cities, as opposed
to European cities.
And this model, plus
the ethos of Chicago,
represents, in more stunning
detail, this phenomenon.
I was talking about Frank Lloyd
Wright and one of his clients.
His clients were new.
They were people like the
man who invented the zip.
They were people willing
to see technology
as a possibility
for advancement.
People made enormous amounts of
money just by being in Chicago.
I'll go through some
of the real estate
transactions in a few minutes.
So the themes we
can look at and I'll
try to give some
examples of, how
the city is an economic engine.
The cycles produced through
advancement and setbacks
in economics has
fascinated cycle theorists
like Kondratiev and Kuznets
and people of this kind.
But nobody has yet been
able to perfect it.
If you perfected
cycle theory, you
would be the wealthiest man
in the world, I should think,
or the wealthiest
women in the world.
But the free market
system implies risk.
And therefore, a
correct depiction
of the way Chicago is built
in the free enterprise system
would suggest a diagram
much like Hoyt's diagram.
Secondly, the city and nature--
there's a wonderful book by
William Cronon called Nature's
Metropolis about Chicago.
It's worth reading if you
have nothing else to do,
which is not likely.
But Nature's
Metropolis is written
by a man who was a
professor at Yale.
And he's now, I think, in
Wisconsin, where he's from.
He's an environmentalist.
And he depicts the
natural state of Chicago,
and its regional hinterland, and
the transformations that occur.
To me, nature in
Chicago was something
that could be improved upon.
As everything else
could be improved
upon through [? manual ?]
labor and intelligence,
so nature could
be improved upon.
Nature could deal with the
consequences of modernism.
I mean, Louis Sullivan,
in Kindergarten Chats--
his little book,
kindergarten chats--
Louis Sullivan was one
of the great architects
of the late 19th
century in Chicago.
He and his partner, Adler, did
the transportation building
in the Chicago
World's Fair in 1893.
But Sullivan-- when I show
you his auditorium building,
you will read in the
toilets the notion that--
no, no sorry.
Forget it.
I'm mixing the ideas.
You will see in the
system of decoration
an attempt to maintain
an association
with natural form, much
like Otto Wagner in Vienna.
These are hybrid people.
Louis Sullivan was very angry
at the neoclassical system
of the Chicago World's Fair.
He said it would set back
America considerably.
We'll talk about the
Chicago World's Fair
later in the class.
Let's look at some
of the other themes.
The distinction
between the activity
of the private sector
and the weakness
of the communal environment--
after the Great Fire of 1871,
there were two responses.
The one was, gee whiz, what an
opportunity to rebuild Chicago
anew.
The other one was, we are guilty
because we blasphemed God.
Two positions
expressed by optimists
It was the day after the fire.
There was a-- you will see--
a real estate booth in
the ashes selling land.
You get, perhaps, the
starkest interpretation
of this theme in the book The
Devil in the White City by Eric
Larson, another
book that you need
to know about if you want
to know about Chicago.
Here, up to 200
women, young women,
are killed by a sociopath
in his hotel, up to 200.
Who know whether it's 200.
Nobody ever was able to account
for the number of bodies
that he either put into
acid vats or burned.
These women just disappeared.
There was no police to
account for who would--
27 million people visited
Chicago for the six months
that the fair ran.
Women just disappeared.
The only way in which Holmes
was a sociopath was discovered
was because of a private
security insurance
man in Philadelphia.
A man named [? Geyer ?]
started tracing
what was happening
in these deaths,
in some of the deaths
that were reported to him.
The Chicago city and the
Chicago Police were ineffable.
So you have this
extraordinary view
of the dark side of an
environment at the same time
as progress is next to what
Burnham called the White City
as opposed to the Dark City.
The White City with this
new Chicago World's Fair.
It had its dark side as well,
the [NON-ENGLISH] But the fact
that in a city as late as 1893--
in Chicago's case, it was
late, it was almost a century
after it was formed, 70 years--
we could have the private
sector maintaining
astounding
technological process.
I will show you a diagram which
compares the Ferris wheel built
by a young engineer from
Pittsburgh for the Chicago
World's Fair.
For the first time,
the public could
circulate above the level
of a city and see it.
This was more astonishing than
the Eiffel Tower four years
before and, perhaps, even
more astonishing than Tatlin's
monument to the
Third International.
This is the city which
again defies logic
by building skyscrapers
without foundation.
Well, the foundations
are rafts which
float on the sand
rather than columns.
There's no rock.
This is the last place in the
world where you would expect
the genesis of the skyscraper.
And the first tall building--
I mean, Otis invented the
elevator, the safety elevator.
Before, the elevators had
been used since Roman times.
But the safety elevator
means that the elevator,
if it breaks, it has the cable
system which protects the fall.
The first skyscrapers,
probably the--
I will get to that.
I wanted-- will detail all of
these things as we go along.
The Chicago World's Fair
was stolen from St. Louis.
St. Louis got the
1904 Olympic games,
the first one held in the
United States and the second one
in modern times.
The first one was 1900 in Paris.
The Chicago World's Fair has a
number of extraordinary things
attached to it.
The one is the building of the
grandest environment ever seen
in this country.
The manufacturer's
building could
house St. Peter's, St.
Paul's, the pyramids,
the lot in one building.
It was massive.
It's extraordinary.
At the same time,
it had a branch
or a road of 600 feet wide
called the midway, where
the vulgar aspects of
honkytonk American culture
could be associated with.
I'll briefly talk about
the idea of the White
City, Reverend Moody's
city in Pullman, Illinois.
What is a Pullman car as opposed
to an ordinary railroad car?
In a Pullman car,
it's business class.
There are black man
dressed in black uniforms
with white gloves
who carry your bags
and elevate the
conventional train system.
120 trains entered near Chicago,
as early as 1857, each day.
Pullman built a new
town at the entrance
to the southern part of Chicago.
You pass Pullman, Illinois
if you came to Chicago
for the World's Fair by train.
Pullman, like many
utopianists, tried
to produce a culturally superior
environment for his workers.
And lastly, we'll
look at Burnham's 1909
plan and subsequent attempts
to modify the girth.
OK, back to the handout.
The first peak,
dated about 1830,
is the building of a
transportation connector,
a canal which connects.
The hypothesis
about Chicago was it
connected the world's
waterways or could
connect it was waterways.
From the Atlantic, here are the
lakes and a small [INAUDIBLE]
You have the widest
river in the world.
This is not a trivial opening.
It never produced
the effect that it
was destined in the minds
of investors to produce.
There's no traffic which
travels along this route.
But it was a
brilliant hypothesis
which, in 1830, enabled
Chicago to take off.
You can see the peak.
The first boom in 1835, land
values increased by 150%
in two years.
I quote from a journalist.
"I have never seen a
busier place than Chicago
at the time of my arrival.
The streets were crowded with
land speculators hurrying
from one sale to another.
A negro dressed in scarlet
bearing a scarlet flag
and riding a white horse with
housing housing of scarlet--
oh-- was housing
[INAUDIBLE] scarlet
announced the time of the sale.
At every street corner, the
crowd gathered behind you."
The total land sales,
according to Hoyt in Chicago,
in 1830 were $168,000.
In 1836, it was $10,500,000,
over 60 times in six years.
1848, the canal was finished.
Chicago was developing as
an agricultural center--
wheat, and lumber, and the
beginning of manufacturing.
But it was a town, I quote,
"without pavement, sidewalks,
sewers, gaslight,
streetcars, or railroads."
The second boom came
with the decision
to have a railroad
pass through in 1848.
Our chief, ultimate importance
of the canal, the lake,
traffic, and the plank
woods for a plank roads
was that they gave Chicago
sufficient advantage
to attract the railroad.
It was important in making
Chicago a great wholesaling
and manufacturing center.
In 1836, it took 30 days to
get from Chicago to New York.
In 1849, it took seven days.
In 1852, it took 36 hours.
[INAUDIBLE] the
time construction
between New York and the
Midwest, when being reduced,
amplified the centrality
of Chicago in the Midwest.
The slump of 1857,
overspeculation
in Western land,
Michigan Southern stock
dropped from $88 to $9.
European demand for wheat
in the 1871 Civil War
meant Chicago kept
economically after.
The post-war boom
of 1865 to 1871
re-established in
Chicago's industrial base.
By now, it had manufactured the
largest meat-packing industry
the world had ever seen using
a conveyor belt system which
Henry Ford, amongst
others, appreciate
and introduced into
his automobile plants.
1871, The Great Fire, one of the
greatest holocausts in history.
The resurrection is
optimism or blame.
1878, the boom, improvement
in the American economic
condition, the first
steel-frame skyscrapers.
Home Insurance building, 1884.
Steel-frame [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] building, 1891.
16 floors.
So on and so on.
So if you're going
to build the city
through private initiative,
private investment,
you're going to have
to deal with the cycle
of economic advancement,
and boom, and depression.
Chicago managed-- you'll notice
that in the European examples,
post-Engels, I spoke often
about the condition of the poor.
The condition of
the poor was not
an aspect of civic
consciousness in the time
that I'm talking about.
If you went to
Chicago, you made it.
If you didn't make
it, somehow or other,
you survived, either by crime
or by some other kind of device.
There was no social program.
The city didn't exist as an
arbiter of human condition.
Human condition followed
what the market produced.
The fire of 1871
paralleled the fire of 1666
in London similarly.
I mentioned the illegal building
of a 50-mile set of tunnels
in 1914.
Earlier, the city, in
1890, had given permission
to private building owners
to dig in their basements
to provide insertion
of a telegraphic wire.
The telegraphic
cable was soon seen
as a ruse for digging mud out
of the basement of your building
and connecting it.
At times, there
was a train which
carried mail and deposited
goods in the basement of Carson
Pririe Scott and Montgomery
Ward, the two biggest modern
department stores at the time.
It even, at times, produced
ice for air conditioning.
It became transportation.
How did the city--
how did the businessmen
deal with it?
By bribes, of course.
That was how all business was
done, also by telling lies.
The developers claimed
that they were only laying
cable for a telephone company.
They dug at night
so people would not
notice the amount of dirt being
smuggled away from the scene.
They found that the tunnels
were almost 13 feet high.
Part of this was
that two people a day
were being killed in
the city by trains going
through crowded crossings.
But this is the only
example in modern history,
or even in any history, of
the illegitimate building
of a major infrastructure
system underneath the city.
It's a wonderful story.
There's a part of
me which rejoices
in the idea of building
an illegal sub,
one day waking up
and finding that you
have a subway system under
your city nobody knew about.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JULIAN BEINART: No, there
was no permission given.
STUDENT: But why?
JULIAN BEINART: But why what?
STUDENT: Why did [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: I
think I've explained
that the city was inevitable.
The city didn't exist.
Local government was
corrupt [INAUDIBLE]
Chicago is known
as the Shock City.
You could get away with
murder, as many people did.
The great murders in the history
of Chicago are not fiction.
They're reality that have become
fiction in American violence.
The fact that human beings
can do extraordinary things
shouldn't surprise us.
The building of the pyramids
was as extraordinary,
if not more extraordinary,
investment in human labor
and guile than the illegal
building of a subway system
in Chicago.
Anyway, the other advent
in Chicago of significance
was the attempt to extend
buildings vertically.
Chicago was hardly
the place that one
would expect this to happen.
There was no rock or
significant rock formation
under the center of the city.
You need at least
that support system
unless you can devise an
alternative, which was devised,
of floating buildings
on platforms.
The Home Insurance
building in 1884
was the first building
built out of a steel frame.
Before that, all building was--
by the way, I forgot to mention.
In 1830s, there was a man--
and not an Indian, an
American white man--
on a canoe on the Chicago River.
He invented something which
transformed the building
industry of the United States.
Well, he devised a system for
manufacturing wooden housing
by using a balloon-frame system
instead of a post and beam.
A balloon-frame system uses
two-by-fours or two-by-tens
and make them into panels which
become the sides of houses,
as opposed to the historic
system of erecting posts
and then spanning
the space with beams.
This man revolutionized the
construction of housing.
And he's little known.
He should be known more widely.
Because since then,
the pervasive building
of single-family
wood construction
has manifested itself as a major
economic force in the United
States.
Anyway, back to the skyscraper.
Under 20 floors of height,
a tall building [INAUDIBLE]
needs to worry about its own
weight and, to a small extent,
about wind.
Above 20 floors, wind
becomes the major factor
in the construction resistance
that you provide to the wind.
These buildings are
all under 20 floors.
Frank Lloyd Wright proposed
a building a mile high.
What was he thinking about?
What did he have in mind?
He wasn't a foolish man.
I'm not quite sure I know, nor
do I know that anybody knows.
The [INAUDIBLE]
building, at that time,
would have been so outside
of any technical calculation
system.
The fact that you may be able
to wrap a city in one building
is interesting.
The John Hancock
building in Chicago--
who knows Chicago well?
Do you know the John
Hancock building?
The John Hancock building,
except for industry,
has all the artifacts of
a city in one building.
There's parking, shopping,
offices, and housing.
Accomplishing this
one in Chicago,
much later than
Frank Lloyd Wright,
perhaps suggests a remodel
that he had in mind
for building a Usonian
utopia vertically.
Frank Lloyd Wright built a small
office building in Oklahoma.
What was the uniqueness
of his building,
the small building in Oklahoma?
Do you know?
It's the only office
building at its time
that had offices and
housing on the same floor.
Here, the separation
is vertical.
I've got to watch
out for the time.
It is long.
Chicago's a long and
interesting convoluted story.
I'm trying to untangle it.
I'd rather leave this
out, but question
as to whether land speculation
in the form of a grid
is a vehicle of
capitalism is arguable.
I've written, disagreeing
with Mumford and Richard
[? Sennett, ?] two formidable
opponents, on this premise.
Mumford, for instance,
says resurgent capitalism
treats the individual lot,
and the block, the street,
and the avenue as abstract
units for buying and selling.
The rectangular street and block
system projected indefinitely
towards the horizon was the
first universal expression
of capitalistic fantasies.
Each lot being of uniform shape
became a unit like a coin,
capable of ready
appraisal and exchange.
Yeah, that means you can buy
a piece of land in Florida
without seeing it.
I suppose that is possible.
But with the grid
system reducing
the complexity of investment
to a unit is all that goes on.
What about [INAUDIBLE] plan?
Here's a man who made an
infinite-- the largest housing
environment in the
world, history.
By using a 113-meter by
113-square-block system,
with infinite variables in
it, not built, but according
to him, to his plan.
Is that a capitalism?
Is that a result of capitalism?
The other example, one
of the largest buildings
of mass housing, is in
Soweto in South Africa.
It's nothing to do
with the market at all.
It was built by a white
government enforcing its power
on--
STUDENT: Well, it actually makes
me think of James C. Scott's
argument about
seeing like a state,
and how states want to
simplify things, and, I mean,
how capitalism uses
those [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah,
I think he's right.
Capitalism does.
If I buy an IBM share, I'm
buying one-hundred-thousandth
of its typewriters
and a hundred-thousand
of its elevators and so on.
Yes.
And of course, that's
understandable.
But whether-- in a city, a
grid system adjacent to a river
is a good deal
different from a grid
system adjacent to a mountain.
They are natural deformations.
And it's not as easy to--
what Mumford is saying is
that in the case of Chicago,
there was no care
given to the modulation
of the size of blocks to who
developed where, and how,
and so on.
He's, in fact, saying
that the free enterprise
system has invaded the spatial
property of a complex city
and reduced it to barrenness.
It's an intriguing
proposition, which I have--
you know, Boston doesn't
have a grid system.
And there's been as
much speculation in land
in Boston as there
has been in Chicago.
So give me a break.
Those of you who
are designers should
stop thinking in terms of
the geometry of things,
in terms of simple outcomes.
STUDENT: I think that's
true in the long term.
But in the short term,
I know specific examples
where a community can't get
a grocery store because it's
an old non-grid layout,
and grocery stores only
want squares or rectangles.
And so there, you have--
it's not because of capitalism,
but temporary market norms,
development norms
realted to the grid.
JULIAN BEINART: What
about Manhattan?
STUDENT: Yeah, It's
not always true.
But it's true of
some [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah,
I always get out
of this by saying cities are
more complicated than I know.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JULIAN BEINART:
There's a juxtaposition
between the market,
and between capitalism,
and goodness of outcomes.
It's like saying the
American Express introduced
the traveler's check
for the first time
at the Chicago Exposition.
And there were new foods,
things like fast food and so on.
Is capitalism to blame for
producing these innovations?
Was capitalism to blame for--
I don't know.
I think it's-- it strikes
me as being too elementary.
Richard Sennett, on the other
hand, has another argument.
I don't have time to go into it.
I want to spend a few minutes
on the World's Fair and then--
the World's Fair,
in many respects,
was fundamental in
the history of Chicago
and, perhaps, fundamental in the
history of the United States.
The Crystal Palace, which is my
favorite 19th-century building,
produced a slew of
exhibitions in Paris.
1851, the Crystal Palace;
1855, 1868, 1889, 1900--
five exhibitions
between 1855 and 1900.
They were all there to promote
technology, newness, modernism,
and the market.
There was no
internet, obviously.
The availability
of information--
there was no telephone.
So this was almost back
to Neanderthal times.
So you needed
these great events.
The Crystal Palace
had pieces of India
in the first part
of the exhibition.
The Crystal Palace genesis
found its last major output
in the 1900 Fair in
Chicago, at least in Paris.
But in 1893, seven years before
Paris, this enormous task
of building an environment
which would be so impressive, so
capitalizing on the energy
that Chicago could generate--
if Chicago could build a
skyscraper-- at the time,
in 1893, there were really
20 skyscrapers in New York.
They had the big
department stores.
They had mass methods of
producing meat and food.
They had enormous grain
towers on the water or next
to the water.
The idea of having
to make something
which manifests itself--
the second problem
with an exhibition
is that it only
lasts a short time.
It's, of course, an
enormous advantage
in that you can risk
building a building which
is more likely to be thrilling
and dangerous than any before.
The story of the Ferris
wheel is a fantastic story.
There was a competition
for a vertical element.
The Eiffel Tower, in
1889, had dramatized
the idea of an exhibition.
Let me just draw this.
Chicago faced the competition
of the Eiffel Tower.
In fact, the competition which
was held, produced, [INAUDIBLE]
fantastic entries.
[INAUDIBLE] wanted to build
a glass umbrella covering 193
acres, four times
larger than St. Peter's.
[? Proctor ?] wants to build a
tower 1,150 feet high, 150 feet
higher than the Eiffel Tower.
The competition was
considered a failure.
Eiffel was contacted and asked
whether he would come and do
something as well.
This is a stark admission
on the part of Chicago
that anybody else in the
world could do better.
Somebody revived the idea
of one of the entries
in the competition
by this young man,
Ferris, who had
proposed that you
could create a vertical
system, in this case--
I don't know what its height--
a system which could do
what the Eiffel Tower--
and I may as well
do Tatlin's Tower.
It was never built--
that you could create an
environment which moved.
36 cars-- the
engineering consequences
of putting people into cars
and then twisting them,
twirling them around in
the air, was significant.
No wonder the Ferris wheel
was considered too dangerous.
And they actually had
to build a model of it.
Well, it's not a model of it.
They built it,
finally, and tested it.
And to everybody's surprise,
but not to Ferris' surprise,
it actually worked.
It ran and provided
a view of Chicago
which people h ad never had.
The Ferris wheel was located
not in the main space
of the exposition.
A significant notion
about the exhibition,
it had the Court of Honor of
these buildings on either side.
You came in by train,
connected to the water
here through a gate, secondary
buildings along here,
the idea--
at right angles to
this, 600 meters--
600 feet in width.
It was something
called the Midway.
The Midway was first
going to be headed
by a man called
[? Putnam, ?] who
was an anthropologist
from Harvard University.
He was going to use
this environment
to depict the human species
in anthropological terms.
He was proposing building a
model of a man and a woman
based on extracting images
from 224 samples of Americans--
something crazy,
all kinds of stuff.
For some reason or other,
Burnham and these people
decided that this was going
to be boring and stupid.
They brought in a man
called Sol Bloom who
was a 25-year-old showman from
San Francisco who had already
produced shows which
brought in Egyptian women
from dances from Egypt and sold
them to American audiences.
Sol Bloom projected
an environment in here
which had Algerian,
Egyptian, foreign
to the American population.
And the Eiffel Tower is located
here, and not in here at all.
So this was the White City.
And this is the city of the--
Octavio Paz says
Americans go to Mexico
to fulfill the deep
recesses of depression,
something of this kind.
There is a wonderful piece,
written many years ago,
called The Social
Uses of the Slum,
arguing that the slum provides
illegal advantages to people
who live outside
it and don't pay
the costs of the
existence of the slum.
So you get the idea that there
are two sides to America.
There's the side of
the establishment
of the symbols of power.
These buildings are bigger.
The Manufacturer's
building is bigger
than anything in history.
[INAUDIBLE] is important
ways of entering.
And this is just at
the road, next to which
are the strangest
things in the world--
not strange anthropologically,
but strange entertainment-wise.
Issues of sexism and racism
clouded America at the time.
1904, the first Olympic
games in St. Louis,
anthropologists
wanted to measure--
he wanted a day
in which he wanted
to measure why Black men
ran faster than white men.
The Chinese-- I could quote
you from the Chicago newspapers
about the Chinese.
Just assume that America
had not liberated itself.
This is premodern America.
It had not liberated itself
from the crutches of--
there was a Woman's Building.
This was not the first time that
a Woman's Building was built.
A Woman's Building was built
in the Philadelphia exhibition
20 years before.
There's something interesting
about the Woman's Building,
which was a fairly
large building designed
by a 21-year-old woman.
There was a kind of competition
which 13 women entered.
Only eight women had graduated
from architecture schools
between '78 and '93.
They were Syracuse,
[? Cooper ?] Union, MIT.
The competition was won by a
21-year-old MIT graduate called
Sophia Hayden, H-A-Y-D-E-N.
Sophia Hayden had a tough time.
She wanted to depict a
modern environment for women.
The people who were paying
the money in Chicago,
the ladies wanted to have a
decorative interior filled
with all of the
fashionable items
that women had in their lives.
Sophia Hayden
suffered a breakdown.
And her story's well told
in the book by [INAUDIBLE]..
On the story of
Holmes, the sociopath,
you have to read the book to get
the nuances of this man's guile
and how he managed to offer
accommodation in his hotel
to young women
visiting the fair.
If there was a black part
opposite to the White City,
it would be this.
I quote from his book.
This is after the police had
investigated the problem.
The earliest phase
of the investigation
began when the police, holding
their flickering lanterns high,
entered the hotel basement,
a cavern of brick and timber
measuring 50 feet by 165 feet.
The discoveries came quickly--
a vat of acid with eight
ribs and part of a skull
settled at the bottom
of mounds of quicklime,
a large [INAUDIBLE] and a
dissection table stained
with what seemed to be blood.
They found surgical tools and
[INAUDIBLE] high-heeled shoes,
bones, 18 ribs from the torso
of a child, and so on and so on.
The book is an
intriguing examination
of what disasters could
befell a city which
was advocating, at the same
time, these kind of displays,
not only for its--
I mean, Americans had
never seen anything
as ordered as in this
environment in 1893.
There are stories.
There are books of reports of
letters written by grandmothers
coming from Idaho or somewhere
to the World's Fair, entering
the Court of Honor
at night and fainting
because they'd never seen
anything made by human beings
quite that way.
The other story which
I think is interesting
is the story of Pullman,
Illinois, the attempt
to build a new town for workers
to build these new railway
cars.
It was an environment which
much paternalism involved itself
in--
that is, to create an
environment in which
the workers would have a higher
level of culture and education
as a result of
living in this town.
Pullman wouldn't allow
people to purchase houses.
He believed that they would
become selfish and indulgent.
He attempted to provide--
he produced the Hotel
Florence in the center
with Black waiters, a
multipurpose arcade containing
the town's post office,
the Pullman loan.
and savings bank, the
arcade theater, the library,
and others.
In fact, there is an element
of the need to civilized people
according to the norms
of somebody, the owner.
In Frank Lloyd
Wright [INAUDIBLE]
projects [INAUDIBLE] talks
about Beethoven being played
in the street or wherever.
Shakespeare, in the
upper part of the arcade,
was meant to appease
these workers who
couldn't have prostitutes,
who weren't allowed alcohol,
and were divorced, and had
to exchange the good life
as destined by
Pullman, who was making
a lot of money out of them.
The workers revolted,
and the National Guard
was called in in 1894,
and Pullman was destroyed.
In 1909, Daniel Burnham, who
was the architect and manager
of the Columbian Exposition,
was asked by the City Business
Club, later become the
City Planning Commission,
to make a plan for Chicago.
I will show you and discuss
it when we look at the slides.
I think let's leave
time for a little
looking at these illustrations.
There subsequently was a plan
done by a German immigrant,
[INAUDIBLE] in 1950 to
reconstruct the grid
system by cutting of
some of the grids.
Maybe I didn't explain
things fully enough.
Is there anything in this
series of sagas, and hypotheses,
and stories, and events
that intrigues you
that I haven't explained fully?
No?
OK.
Well, then, I've
done a good job.
The wild garlic piece of
land between the Lac des
Ilinois and the
Mississippi River
is the genesis of
the city of Chicago.
Its history of development
is best explained
by Hoyt's analysis.
Next.
Here's the river and the
first layout of blocks.
That's a view of
the town in 1845.
Next.
This is after the railroad.
The fire which, again, as
in London, starts with ships
and eliminates this
large black area--
one of the major urban
fires in history.
Next.
Through the flames and
beyond, as it was and as
it is, Wells and Company.
Post-fire, a real estate agent.
Next.
Chicago kept on spreading.
This is 1893.
Next.
The [INAUDIBLE] building,
I think about 20 floors
in height.
The traction system for
use in the [INAUDIBLE]
in the meatpacking industry.
Next.
Some people argue
that the French,
the Parisian exhibitions
had to produce
all the technology which wasn't
available in the city itself.
Some people argued the
Chicago World's Fair
had all of these infrastructure
already in existence
in the city itself.
Next.
This is the ladies toilets
of the Auditorium building.
Here is a city, and this
is part of Louis Sullivan's
decorative system.
a city which is rough
and speeding along
has another aspect to it.
You could argue that
cities should first
make money and then
reculture themselves.
The first [INAUDIBLE]
argued in the Third World
economic environment
that first, make cities.
For instance, an alternative
to [? Chandigarh ?]
was presented as a
city of mud growing,
eventually, into a city of gold.
The images is that
the important thing
is to establish the economic
system, make it work.
And then invest in the
superficial aspects
or the superior
aspects of culture.
Here, in a city in
which there aren't
proper streets, in which people
get killed in the street,
get killed anywhere else, here
is the cultural contribution.
This is what the new
middle class need to enjoy.
Next.
The part of the Colombian
exhibition which involved
the Court of Honor, the
major buildings on the flank
and the electricity building,
the [INAUDIBLE] building
[INAUDIBLE] administration,
entry by train,
the base and statue of
the Republic, the harbour,
and so on.
Next.
The Woman's Building, you
can see the Midway Plaisance
in the distance with
the Ferris wheel
in position, as opposed to
the neoclassical facades
of the old part
of the exhibition.
Next.
Extraordinary historical
devices-- the crescent,
the arch, the
isolated sculpture.
Next.
Louis Sullivan and Adler's
Transportation building whilst
Sullivan rejected
the neoclassicism
of this exhibition.
He nevertheless had
enough attraction to it
to build this building.
The Administration
building, with a dam
which is larger than the
Capitol in Washington.
Next.
Sorry, I made a mistake.
This is a Woman's
Building by Sophia Hayden.
In the interior of
the Woman's Building,
a mixture of new
electrical equipment
for the modern kitchen
and half-nude women
dressed up in drapery as the
other half of the woman's life.
Next.
Ferris wheel.
And you can see the Austrian
village, the Algerian,
the Moorish Palace, the street
of Cairo, the German village,
the Javanese village.
Next.
That's Sol Bloom, a
little older than 25.
Next.
There's a kind of
hybridity in looking
at the history of cities.
You could argue that
almost any city in motion
will produce hybrid
versions of situations.
We've had a hybrid version
of the independent woman--
on the one hand, dressed up as
a nude model; on the other hand,
percolating over a new
toaster in the kitchen.
The same with the
American psyche--
what do you go and see, the
largest manufacturing building
in the world?
Or come and enjoy
yourself seeing
the exotics of Cairo street?
Next.
It all ends very quickly with
fires, one in the cold storage
environment, another in the
Manufacturer's building.
And this whole place is ruined.
And it's back to scratch.
Next.
Pullman, Illinois,
the Florence Hotel
on the right with
the clock tower,
the typical plan of an
industrial manufacturing town.
Next.
The Arcade, perhaps one
of the earliest shopping
centers in the United States.
Next.
1894, the workers and
the National militia
are called out to
protect Pullman.
Next.
Burnham, on the extreme left,
at the City Business Club
and his plan to create a girdle
around the city, six miles out,
and to diagonalize
the grid where
possible with diagonal systems,
leading to a newly created
center civic promenade and
a large cultural enterprise
along the waterfront
and the harbor.
Next.
Originally, all the railroads
would follow the same pattern,
entering the center of the city.
The park system would
be greenery located
in [INAUDIBLE] system.
Next.
Burnham had large
drawings of Paris.
Haussmann was a long
time in advance.
But neoclassical Paris was what
Burnham was using as a model.
Next.
This is the German
urbanist, [INAUDIBLE]
attempt to revise
the grid system
by cutting it in to
different systems,
breaking it up in
places, leaving it
where it is in
places, instituting
a different [INAUDIBLE]
in some places,
and really revamping
the whole system.
He was also attracted
by [INAUDIBLE]
tall office building
and residential towers
as a proposition.
Next.
And the last of this is
Mario Gandelsonas' book
The Urban Text, an attempt to
take the grid and the river
and to reframe it, is best I
can put it, as a set of steps
that you take in reconstructing
the deep structure of this grid
and river into systems
that look like that.
Peter [? Eisenman ?] used the
system in studios at Harvard.
If we have a chance at
one of the next classes,
I will show some of that work.
It's a set of--
it's based on the
notion that you
can dig deeply into
of an environment,
reconstruct it, and
re-elementize it
in a new way, which is that.
I don't know what
the hell it means.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JULIAN BEINART: It has
no practical value.
You should look at the
book The Urban Text
and decide on your own.
I'll give you my opinion.
Chicago is now considered as
one of the greenest cities
in the United States.
What does that mean?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Sorry?
STUDENT: The green spaces
are mostly private.
JULIAN BEINART: Does it
matter what they are?
Certainly not as far as
the environment, the air,
and pollution is concerned.
If you privatized all
the roofs of buildings
and made them green, you'd
have an enormous effect
on the energy output in a city.
I'll just leave--
if you want to,
I'll give you the reference
to the study which
posits Chicago is the greatest
city in the United States.
It's largely the greening
of the roofs of buildings.
Chicago can do anything.
It's an example of a
city as an artifact which
manufactures-- re-manufactures
itself almost at will,
just through a kind
of sense and will.
I mean, that sense of will--
STUDENT: How much
of that will gets
lost once the city
becomes institutionalized?
JULIAN BEINART: A lot.
You just can't bribe
your way through.
No, absolutely.
Chicago as a story is
a story of free will.
Anybody coming in from anywhere
making it, and behaving
like an important person.
STUDENT: There's a sense
of rapaciousness in the DNA
that you showed.
JULIAN BEINART: Absolutely,
absolutely, absolutely.
The social cost of the
free-sector environment was
slowly picked up
as the country--
I mean, this was a pretty--
[INAUDIBLE] I was
trying to think
of the percentage
of Black people
in this country who still
live below the poverty line.
I think [? 16%, ?] or 50%
of the Black population
lived below the
poverty line in 2013.
This is from William Julius
Jones' work at Harvard.
And the statistics
are borne out.
This country has never
caught up with the capacity
to socialize poverty.
It's assumed that--
Mitt Romney is an arch
example of somebody
who believes that the free
market system will eventually
produce enough social
benefit to take
care of the exaggerations
of the market.
I don't know what else to say.
It's such a big generalization.
We'll come into it
later in this class.
Certainly, the European cities,
from Engels onwards, face the--
and the Communist
Party never had
any leverage in this country.
The trade union
movement in this country
doesn't resemble the
British trade union
movement in any way at all.
The British trade union movement
educates people in voting,
for instance.
The American trade
union movement is--
half of the American South
doesn't involve the trade union
anyway.
And that's where most of the new
automobile manufacturing plants
are going.